The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: All right, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Let's get started.
So today's lecture will be on
testing, debugging, and then
exceptions and assertions.
So before we begin, let's start
with an analogy to sort of come
back to real life for a second.
So I've made soup before.
Perhaps you've made soup before.
Let's say you're making
soup in this big pot here.
And it turns out that bugs
keep falling into your soup
from the ceiling.
All right.
Quick question to the audience.
What do you do if you
encountered this issue?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Hands up.
One one at a time.
Anyone have any idea?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Eat it.
PROFESSOR: Eat it.
You want to eat it Anyway OK.
All right.
We're going for an analogy
here with computer programming.
I don't know what you'd do
if you have a buggy program,
I guess you just release
it to the customer
and they'd complain, but.
OK.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Cover the soup?
PROFESSOR: Cover the soup.
That's a good suggestion.
Yeah.
So you can cover the
soup, so put a lid on it.
Sometimes you'd have to
open up, take the lid off,
right, to check to
make sure it's done.
To taste it, add things.
So bugs might fall
in in between there.
But covering the
soup is a good idea.
What else.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Debug it.
PROFESSOR: Debug it.
I wish I had something
for that answer.
All right.
That's a good answer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Take all the
food out of your house
so there's no-- nothing
for the bugs to eat.
PROFESSOR: So take all
the food out of your house
so there's nothing
for the bugs to eat.
That's sort of the
equivalent of cleaning,
like doing a mass cleaning
of your entire house.
That's a good,
that's a good one.
That's sort of eliminating
the source of the bugs, right?
What else?
Yeah, John.
AUDIENCE: Decide
it's high protein
and declare it a feature.
PROFESSOR: Decide
it's high protein
and declare it a feature.
That's probably what a lot
of people would do, right?
All right.
Cool.
So I wish computer debugging
was as fun as taking bugs out
of your soup.
So what did we decide?
Well we could check
the soup for bugs.
Keep the lid closed, that
was a good suggestion.
And cleaning your kitchen,
which someone suggested.
The equivalent of
cleaning their kitchen
was to just throw
out all the food.
I would take a mop
and clean the floor,
but yeah, that works too.
So we can draw some
parallels for this analogy
with computer programming.
So checking the soup is really
equivalent to testing, right?
You have a soup you
think has bugs in it.
Test it.
Make sure there's no bugs.
Continue on.
Keeping the lid closed.
It's sort of this idea
of defensive programming.
So make sure that bugs don't
fall in in the first place.
Sometimes you have
to open the lid
to make sure that the soup
is tastes good or whatever.
So that's equivalent to
defensive programming.
So try not to have bugs
in the first place,
but they might show up anyway.
Cleaning the kitchen is
eliminating the source
of the bugs in the first place.
This is actually really
hard to do in programming.
But you can still try to do it.
OK.
So let's talk a little
bit about programming
so far in 60001 600.
So you expect, really,
that you write a program,
you maybe do a little debugging,
and you run the program
and it's perfect.
Right?
You just nailed it.
But in reality you write this
really complex piece of code
and you go to run
it and it crashes.
Right?
It's happened to me many times.
It's happened to you many times.
That's the reality.
OK.
So today's lecture will go
over some tips and tricks
and debugging and how you can
help make your life easier
when you're writing
programs so you don't end up
like this little girl here.
Disappointed beyond belief.
All right.
So at the heart of
it all is really
starting with a defensive
programming attitude.
OK.
And this comes back to
the idea of decomposition
and abstraction that we talked
about when we started-- when we
did the lecture on functions.
Right?
So try to start out with two
modularize your code, right?
If you write your code
in different blocks,
documenting each
different block,
you're more likely to understand
what's happening in your code
later on and you'll be
able to test it and debug
it a lot easier.
Speaking of testing
and debugging,
once you've written a
program that's modular,
you still have to test it.
And the process of
testing is really just
coming up with inputs.
Figuring out what
outputs you expect.
And then running your program.
Does the output that the program
give match what you expected?
If it does, great, you're done.
But if it doesn't, you have
to go to this debugging step.
And the debugging step
is the hardest part.
And it's really just figuring
out why the program crashed,
or why the program didn't
give you the answer that you
expected it to give.
So as I mentioned, the
most important thing
is to do defensive
programming and to that end,
you want to set yourself up
for easy testing and debugging.
Which really comes
down to making sure
that the code you
write is modular.
So write as many
functions as you can.
Document what the functions do.
Document their constraints.
And it'll make your life a
little bit easier later on
when you have to debug it.
When do you want
to start testing?
Well first you have to make
sure your program runs.
So eliminate syntax errors
and static semantic errors
which, by the way, Python
can easily catch for you.
Once you've ensured that
a piece of code runs,
then you want to come
up with some test cases.
So this is pairs
of input and output
for what you expect
the program to do.
Once you have your test cases
and a piece of code that runs,
you can start doing tests.
So there's three general classes
of tests that you can do.
The first is called
unit testing.
And if you've written functions,
unit testings-- testing just
makes sure that, for example,
each function runs according
to the specifications.
So you do this multiple times.
As you're testing each
function, you might find a bug.
At that point, you do
regression testing.
Come up with a test case
that found that bug.
And run all of the different
pieces of your code again
to make sure that
when you fix the bug,
you don't re-introduce new bugs
into pieces of the code that
had already run.
So you do this a bunch of times.
You do a little bit
of unit testing,
a little bit of regression
testing, and keep doing that.
At some point, you're ready
to do integration testing.
Which means, test your
program as a whole.
Does the overall program work?
So this is the
part where you take
all of the individual
pieces, put them together.
And integration testing
tests to make sure
that the interactions between
all of the different pieces
works as expected.
If it does, great, you're done.
But if it doesn't,
then you'll have
to go back to unit testing, and
regression testing, and so on.
So it's really a
cycle of testing.
So what are some
testing approaches?
The first, and this is probably
most common with programs
that involve numbers,
is figuring out
some natural boundaries for
the numbers-- for the program,
sorry.
So for example, if I have
a function is_bigger,
and it compares if
x is bigger than y,
then some natural boundary,
given the specification,
is if x is less than
y, x is greater than y,
x is equal to y.
Maybe throw in less than
or equal to or greater
or equal to, and so on.
So that's just sort of an
intuition about the problem.
It's possible you have some
problems for which there
are no natural partitions.
In which case, you might
do some random testing,
and then the more
random testing you
do, the greater the likelihood
that your program is correct.
But there's actually two more
rigorous ways to do testing.
And one is black box
testing and the other one
is glass box testing.
In black box testing,
you're assuming
you have the specifications
to a function.
So that's the docstring.
All you're looking at is
the docstring and coming
up with some test
cases based on that.
In glass box testing,
you have the code
itself and you're
trying to come up
with some test cases that hit
upon all of the possible paths
through the code.
All right.
Let's look at an example
for black box testing.
I'm finding the square root of
x to some close enough value
given by this epsilon.
And the idea here,
notice I don't actually
give you how this
function's implemented.
The idea is that you're
just figuring out test cases
based on the specification.
And the great thing
about black box testing
is that whoever implements
this function can implement it
in whatever way they wish, they
can use approximation method,
that can use bisection
method, it doesn't matter.
The test cases that you come
up with for this function
are going to be
exactly the same.
Right?
No matter what the
implementation.
So for this particular
function, here's a sample set.
We check the boundary,
we check perfect squares,
we can check some number
that's less than 1,
we can check maybe irrationals,
and then you do extreme tests.
So when either epsilon is
really large or epsilon
is really small, or x is really
large or x is really small,
and all the possible
combinations of those.
So the important thing
about black box testing
is that you are doing you are
creating the test cases based
on the specifications only.
Glass box testing, you're
using the code itself
to guide your test cases.
So if you have a piece
of code and you come up
with a test case that goes
through every single possible
combination of input-- of
every single possible path
through the code, then that test
set is called path complete.
The problem with this is
when you encounter loops,
for example.
Every single possible
path through a loop
is maybe the code not going
through the loop at all,
going through once,
going through twice,
going through three times, four
times, five times, and so on.
Right?
Which could be a
very, very big test.
So instead there are
actually some guidelines
for when you're dealing with
loops and things like that.
So for branches, when you're
doing glass box testing,
it's important-- you
should just exercise
all of the parts
of the conditional.
So make sure you
have a test case that
goes through each part
of the conditional.
For for loops, make sure
you have a test case where
the loop is not entered at all,
where the loop is entered one
time, and when the loop is
entered just some number more
than once.
For while loops,
similar to for loops,
except that make sure
you have test cases that
cover all of the possible ways
to break out of the while loop.
So if the while loop condition
becomes false, or if maybe
there's a break inside
the while loop, and so on.
So in this example, we have
the absolute value of x.
This is its specification and
this is the implementation
that someone decided to
do for this function.
So a path complete
test set means
that you want to
have a test that
goes through each one
of these branches.
So if x is less than
minus 1, well, minus 2
is less than minus 1.
So that's good.
And otherwise, which means pick
a number greater than minus 1.
So 2.
So 2 and minus 2
are path complete.
Yield path complete-- yields
a path complete test suite.
But notice that while we've
hit upon every possible path
through this code, we've
actually missed a test case.
Minus 1.
So this code incorrectly
classifies minus 1
as returning minus
1, which is wrong.
So for glass box
testing, in addition to
making sure you're going
through all the possible paths
through the code,
you also want to make
sure you hit upon any
boundary condition.
So in this case, for
branches, minus 1
is a boundary condition.
So you've created a test suite,
you've tested your program,
chances are you found a bug.
What do you do now?
All right.
Quick sort of detour into
a little bit of history.
The history of debugging.
So 1947, this
computer was built.
And it was a computer that was
very impressive for its day.
It could do things like
addition in 0.1 seconds.
Things like multiplication
in 0.7 seconds.
And take the log of
something in five seconds.
So faster than a
human, possibly.
But pretty slow for
today's standards.
And a group of
engineers were working
on running a
program that found--
that was supposed to find
the trigonometric function.
And among them being this-- one
of the first female scientists,
Grace Hopper.
And they found that
their program was not
working correctly.
So they went through all of the
panels and all of the relays
in the computer, and
they isolated a program
in panel F relay 70, where
they found this moth.
Just sitting in there.
I think it was dead,
probably electrocuted.
But it was a moth that was
impeding the calculation.
And I don't know if you can read
this, but this part right here.
They made a note
in their logbook
that says, first actual
case of bug being found.
Which I think is really cute.
So they were literally doing
debugging in this computer.
Right.
All right.
So you won't be doing
that sort of debugging.
You'll be doing a virtual kind
of debugging in your programs.
Which, again, is not that fun.
But you still have to do it.
So debugging, as you might have
noticed so far in your problem
sets, has a bit of a
steep learning curve.
And obviously your goal is
to have a bug free program,
and in order to achieve that,
you have to do the debugging.
There are some tools which
some of you have been using.
There are some tools
built into Anaconda,
or whatever ID you've been
using to do debugging.
I know some of you have been
using the Python tutor, which
is awesome.
The print statement can also
be a good debugging tool.
But over above
everything else, it's
really important to
just be systematic
as you're trying to
debug your program.
I want to talk a little
bit about print statements
and how you can use them
to debug, because I think--
Python tutor, if you
don't have the internet,
you might not be able to use it.
If you don't know how
to use the debugger,
you don't need to learn.
But print statements,
you'll always have them,
and you can always put
them in your program.
And they're really good
ways to test hypotheses.
So good places to
put print statements
are inside functions.
Inside loops, for example,
what are the loop parameters,
what are the loop values,
what function-- what
functions return what values.
So you can make sure that
values are being passed--
the correct values
are being passed
between parts of your code.
I will mention that you
can use the bisection
method when you're debugging.
Which is interesting.
So if you take a
print statement,
find approximately the
halfway point in your code.
Print out what values you--
print out some relevant values.
All of the possible--
print out some
values at that
point in your code.
If everything is
as you expect it
to be at that point in your
code, then you're good.
That means the code
so far is bug free.
That means that-- however, that
means that the code beyond it
has a bug, right?
So since you've put a print
statement halfway in your code
and you think that
gave good results,
then put a print statement
3/4 of the way in the code.
And see if the values are
as you expect at that point.
And if they are, great.
Then put a print
statement further down.
So in this way you could
use the bisection method
to pinpoint a line, or a set
of lines, or maybe a function
that that's giving
you the bad results.
So the general debugging steps
is to study the program code.
Don't ask what is wrong,
because that's actually
part of the testing.
So your test cases would have
figured out what's wrong.
The debugging process
is figuring out
how the result took place.
And since programming is--
programming and debugging
is, sort of, is a science, you
can use the scientific method
as well.
So look at all the data,
that's your test cases.
Figure out a hypothesis.
Maybe say, oh, maybe I'm
indexing from 1 instead of 0
in lists, for example.
Come up with an experiment
that you can repeat.
And then pick a
simple test case then
you can test your
hypothesis with.
So as you're debugging, you
will encounter error messages.
And these error
messages are actually
pretty easy to figure out.
And they're really easy
to fix in your code.
So for example, accessing things
beyond the limits of the lists
give you index errors.
Trying to convert, in this
case, a list to an integer
gives you type errors.
Accessing variables that
you haven't created before
gives you name errors.
And so on and so on.
And syntax errors are
things, for things like,
if you forget a parentheses,
or forget a colon,
or something like that.
So error messages are
really easy to spot.
The Python interpreter
spits these out for you
and then you can
pinpoint the exact line.
Logic errors are
actually the hard part.
And logic errors are
the ones that you will
be spending the most time on.
For which I would recommend
always trying to take a break.
Take a nap, go eat.
Something.
Sometimes you'd have
to start all over, so
throughout the code
you have and just
sit down with a piece of
paper, try to figure out how
you want to solve the problem.
And if you look up the term
rubber ducky-- a lot of heads
went up on that one--
rubber ducky debugging.
That is an actual
term in Wikipedia.
And it's when a programmer
explains their code
to a rubber ducky.
That's me on the left explaining
code to my rubber ducky.
You should always--
you should go buy one.
Or code to anyone else,
preferably someone
who doesn't really
understand anything.
Because that'll force you to
explain everything really,
really closely.
And as you're doing that,
you'll figure out your problem.
And I figured out my problem
in both of these cases.
So just go back to the basics.
Quick summary of dos and don'ts
of debugging and testing.
So don't write the
entire program,
test the entire program, and
debug the entire program.
I know this is really
tempting to do,
and I do it all the time.
But don't do it.
Because you're
going to introduce
a lot of bugs and
it's going to be
hard to isolate which bugs
are affecting other ones.
And it'll lead to a lot
more stress than you need.
Instead do unit testing.
So write one function, test the
function, debug the function,
make sure it works,
write the other function,
and so on and so on.
Do a little regression
testing, a little more unit
testing, a little
integration testing,
and it's a lot more systematic
way to write the program.
And it'll cut down on your
debugging time immensely.
If you're changing your
code, and inevitably you'll
be changing your code as
you're doing your problem sets,
remember to back up your code.
So if you have a version
that almost works,
don't just modify that
and maybe save a copy.
[INAUDIBLE] you've got terabytes
of memory on your computer,
it won't hurt to just
make a quick copy of it.
Document maybe what worked
and what didn't in that copy.
And then make another copy, and
then you can modify your code.
So that's sort of a
high level introduction
to testing and debugging.
The rest of the class will
be on the error messages,
or on errors that you
will get in your programs.
So when your functions--
when you run functions,
or when you run your
program, at some point,
the program execution
is going to stop.
Maybe it encountered
an error because
of some unexpected condition.
And when that happens
you get an exception.
So the error is
called an exception.
And it's called an exception
because it was an exception
to what was expected.
To what the program expected.
So all of these errors
that I've talked
about in the previous
slides are actually
examples of exceptions.
And there are actually
many other types
of exceptions, which you'll
see as you go on in this course
and also in 60002.
So how do we deal
with these exceptions?
In Python, you can actually
have handlers for exceptions.
So if you know that a piece of
code might give you an error.
For example, here I'm dealing
with inputs from users.
And users are really
unpredictable.
You tell them to
give you a number,
they might give you their name.
Nothing you can do about that.
Or is there?
Yes there is.
So in your program you can
actually put any lines of code
that you think might
be problematic,
that might give you an error an
exception, in this try block.
So you say try colon, and
you put in any lines of code
that you think might
give you an error.
If none of these lines of code
actually produce an error,
then great.
Python doesn't do anything else.
It treats them as just
part-- as just if they
were part of a regular program.
But if an error does
come up-- for example,
if someone doesn't
put in a number
but puts their name
in-- that's going
to raise an error,
specifically a value error.
And at that point,
Python's going to say,
is there an accept statement?
And if so, this except statement
is going to handle the error.
And it's going say,
OK, an error came up,
but I know how to handle it.
I'm going to print out
this message to the user.
So if we look at code--
this is the same code
as in the slides-- and there's
no try except block around it.
So if I run it and I
say, three and four,
it's going to run fine.
But if I run it and
I say, [INAUDIBLE] a,
it's going to give
a value error.
Now if I run the same
piece of code with
try-- with a try except block.
I run it, if I give it
regular numbers, it's fine.
But if I'm being a cheeky
user, and I say three,
automatically this would
have raised the value error
in the previous
version of the program.
But in this version
of the program,
the programmer
handled the exception
or caught the
exception, and printed
out this nicer looking message.
So bug in user input is nicer
than this whole lot here.
A lot easier to read.
So any problematic
lines of code,
you can put in a
try block, and then
handle whatever errors might
come up in this except block.
This except block is going to
catch any error that comes up.
And you can actually get
a little bit more specific
and catch specific
types of errors.
In this case, I'm saying,
if a value error comes up--
for example, if the user
inputs a string instead
of an integer-- do this, which
is going to print this message.
If the user inputs a
number for B such that
we're doing a divided by b, so
that would give a 0 division
error.
In that case we're going to
catch this other error here,
the 0 division error,
and we're going
to print this other
message, can't divide by 0.
So each-- so you can think of
these different except blocks
as sort of if else
if statements,
except for exceptions.
So we're going to try this.
But if there's a
value error do this.
Otherwise, if there's a
division error, do this.
And otherwise do this.
So this last except
is actually going
to be for any other
error that comes up.
So if it's not a value error,
nor a division error, then
we're going to print,
something went very wrong.
I couldn't even try to
create-- I couldn't even
try to make the program
come up with any other error
besides those two.
So a lot of the time you're just
going to use try except blocks.
But there's other blocks that
you can add to exceptions.
And these are more
rarely used, but I'll
talk about them anyway.
So you could have an else block.
And an else block is
going to get executed
when the code in the
try block finished
without raising an error.
And you can also
have a finally block,
which is always executed.
If the code in the try block
finished without an error,
if you raised an
exception, if you raised
a different kind of exception,
if you went through the else,
in any of these cases,
whatever's in the finally block
is always going to get executed.
And it's usually used
to clean up code.
Like if you want to print,
oh, the program finished,
or if you want to close a
file, or something like that.
So.
We've encountered errors.
We've caught them.
What else can we do with
errors-- with exceptions.
Three other things.
So one is if we've
caught an error,
we can just fail silently.
What this means is,
you've caught an error,
and you just substitute whatever
erroneous value the user gave
you for some other value.
That's not actually
a very good idea.
That's a bad idea.
Because suddenly the user thinks
that they entered something,
and they think everything's
great, your program accepts it,
but then they get
some weird value
as an output, which is far
from what they expected.
So it's not really a
good idea to just replace
user's values with anything.
In the context-- so this is
in the context of a function.
In the context of a function,
what else can we do?
Well, if you have a
function that fails,
for example, let's say
you're trying to do you're
trying to get the square
root of an even number.
And let's say the user
gives you a-- sorry,
you're trying to find the square
root of a positive number.
And let's say the user
gives you a negative number.
Well, if the user gives
you a negative number,
your function could return
an error value, which
means, well if the number
inputted is less than 0,
then return 0.
Or minus 1.
Or minus 100.
Just pick any value
to return which
represents some error value.
This is actually not a good
idea either, because later
on in your program, if
you're using this function,
now you have to do a check.
And the check is, well if
the return from this function
is minus 1 or
minus 100, do this.
Otherwise, do this.
So you you're
complicating your code
because now you always have to
have this check for this error
value.
Which makes the
code really messy.
The other thing we can do is we
can signal an error condition.
So this is how you create
control flow in your programs
with exceptions.
So in Python, signaling
an error condition
means raising your
own exception.
So so far we've just seen
the programs crashing,
which means they
raise an exception
and then you deal with them.
But in this last case, you're
raising your own exception.
As a way to use that exception
later on in the code.
So in Python, you raise
your own exception
using this raise keyword
and then an exception.
And then some sort
of description,
like "user entered a negative
number" or something like that.
A lot of the time we're
going to raise a value error.
So if the number is less than
0, then raise a value error,
something is wrong.
The key word, the name
of the error, and then
some sort of descriptive string.
So let's see an example of
how we raise an exception.
I have this function
here called get ratios.
It takes in two
lists, L1 and L2.
And it's going to
create a new list that's
going to contain the
ratio of each element
in L1 divided by
each element in L2.
So I have a for loop here.
For index in range length L1.
So I'm going through every
single element in L1.
I'm going to try here.
I'm going to try
to do this line.
So I think that this line
might give me an error.
So I'm going to put
it in a try block.
The error I think
I'm going to get
is a 0 division error,
because what happens
when an element and L2 is 0?
And when an element
in L2 is 0 I'm
going to append this
not a number as a float.
So NAN, as a string, you
can convert it to a float,
and it stands for not a number.
So then I can continue
populating the list
with these not a numbers.
If an element and L2 is 0.
And otherwise, if there's
no 0 division error,
but there's another
kind of error,
then I'm going to
raise my own error.
And say, for any
other kind of error,
just raise a value error.
Which says, "get ratios was
called with a bad argument."
So here I'm sort of
consolidating all errors
into my one value error.
So later on in my program,
I can catch this value error
and do something with it.
Here's another
example of exceptions.
So let's say we're were
given a class list.
We have a list of lists.
Where we have the
name of a student,
first name and last name, and
their grades in the class.
So we currently
have two students.
And what I want to do
is create a new list
which is the same things,
the same inputs here.
But I'm adding an extra--
I'm appending an extra value
at the end of the list
for each student, which
is the average of
all of their grades.
Or all of their-- yeah,
So let's look at the code.
This is the function that
takes the class list, which
is this whole list here.
I'm creating a new list
inside it, initially empty.
And then I'm going for every
element in the class list.
I'm appending element
at 0, which is going
to be this first list here.
So it's going to be the
first name and the last name.
Element at 1, which
is the grades.
And then the last thing I'm
appending is a function call.
The function call being
called with element 1, which
is all of the grades, and
this is my function call.
We're going to see three
different function calls.
This is the first one.
It simply takes the
sum of the grades
and divides it by the
length of the grades.
If these students
are responsible,
and they've taken all of the
tests, then there's no problem.
Because length of grades
is going to be something
greater than 0.
But what if we have a
student in the class who
didn't show up for any tests?
Then we have no record
of any of their tests.
No record of grades
or anything like that.
So they're going to
have an empty list.
So if we run this function,
averages, on their data,
we're actually going to get a
0 division error, because we're
trying to divide by length of
grades, which is going to be 0.
So what can we do?
Two things, two options here.
One is we can just flag the
error and print the message.
So here there's a new average
function, an improved one,
that's going to try to
do the exact same line
as the previous one.
And it's going to catch
the 0 division error.
And when it catches it, it's
going to print this warning.
And when we run it, we're
going to get, "warning,
no grades data," which is fine.
And we're going to get this
"none" here, for the grades.
So everyone else's grades
was calculated correctly,
and for this last
one, we got a none.
That's because, when we
entered this except statement,
if this is a function, remember
functions return something.
This function in this
particular except statement
didn't return anything.
So it returns a none.
So for the averages for
this particular function,
the average is going to be
a "none" for this person who
didn't have any grades
associated with them.
And yeah, so that's
basically what I said.
So that's our first option,
is to just flag the error
and print a message.
The other option is to
actually change the policy.
So this is where you replace the
data with some sort of default
value.
And if you do
something like this,
then this should be documented
inside the function.
So when you write the
docstring for the function,
you would say if the list is
empty, then it'll will a 0.
So this is the exact
same thing as before.
We have a try and an except
for the 0 division error.
We also print a
warning, no grades data.
And then we return the 0.
So we still flag the error,
and now instead of a "none,"
we get a 0, because we've
returned 0.0 here, as opposed
to just leaving it blank.
All right.
So those are exceptions.
Last thing we're going
to talk about today
are these things
called assertions.
And assertions are good example
of defensive programming.
In that, you have
assert statements
at the beginning of
functions, typically.
Or at the end of functions.
And assert statements
are used to make sure
that the assumptions
on computations
are exactly what the
function expects them to be.
So if we have a
function that says
it's supposed to take in
an integer greater than 0,
then the assert
statement will assert
that the function takes in an
integer that's greater than 0.
Here's an example.
This is the same average
function we've seen before.
Here, instead of
using exceptions,
we're going to use
an assert statement.
And the assert statement we're
putting right at the front.
At the beginning of
the function, sorry.
And the key word is assert.
The next part of the assert
is what the function expects.
So we expect that the length
of grades is not equal to 0.
So has to be greater than 0.
And then we have a
string here, which
represents what do you print out
if the assertion does not hold.
So if you run the
function, and you give it
a list that is empty,
this becomes false,
so the assert is
false, and we're
going to print out an assertion
error, no grades data.
If the assert is false, the
function does not continue.
It stops right there.
Why does it behave this way?
Well, assertions are
great to make sure
that preconditions and
post-conditions on functions
are exactly as you expect.
So as soon as an
assert becomes false,
the function's going to
immediately terminate.
This is useful because
it'll prevent the program
from propagating bad values.
So as soon as a precondition
isn't true, for example,
as you enter a function,
then that means something
went wrong in your program.
And the program is going
to stop right there.
So instead of
propagating a bad value
throughout the
program, and then you
getting an output that
you didn't expect,
and then you having to trace
back to the function that
gave this bad value, you'll get
this bad value, you'll get this
assert being false
a lot earlier.
So it'll be a lot
easier to figure out
where the bug came from.
And you won't have to
trace back so many steps.
So this is basically
what I said,
you really want to spot the bugs
as soon as they're introduced.
And exceptions are good
if you want to raise them
when the user supplies
bad data input,
but assertions are
used to make sure
that the types and other-- the
types of inputs to functions,
maybe other conditions
on inputs to functions,
are being held as the
values are being passed in.
So the keyword
here is making sure
that the invariants on
data structures are meant.
And that's it.
Great.
Thanks.